I'd like to share with our viewers we
had the opening ceremony yesterday of
the three events as they're the drawing
of lots Tony Rich
the executive director of St Louis chess
club introduced all the players Chris
bird our chief Arbiters and these were
the bags yeah that was a drawing of laws
they were picking a bag and there was a
number at the bottom of each bag and
that's how they picked the number
they're going to start with in the
exactly remember in these round Robins
you have nine rounds of play because
everybody plays everyone Joe Benjamin
very celebrating the fact that he got
number one he picked the number one
number
and uh yeah it wasn't just happiness
over the back right I mean it was the
number one pick and the idea is nine
games you're gonna get five whites or
five blacks and getting that extra white
so choosing numbers one through five is
something to be used celebrated